[Musique]
bienvenue en débat sur france 24 avec ce
soir un format un peu particulier
puisque vous allez pouvoir voir
l'interview exclusive du ministre des
affaires étrangères et des affaires
européennes jean yves le drian une
interview exclusive pour france 24 et
rfi c'est à 19h30 en direct donc dans
une vingtaine de minutes et avant cela
et bien on va s'interroger sur le rôle
de la france dans le monde qu'est ce qui
caractérise la diplomatie française
comment la définir quel bilan finalement
peut-on faire de la politique étrangère
des manuels macron va poser la question
à nos deux invités j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés michel duclos
bonsoir souple aux mathes conseiller
spécial à l'institut montaigne hauteur
de la france dans le bouleversement du
monde et c'est aux éditions de
l'observatoire bienvenue à vous vincent
riou est avec nous un bon soir vincent
journaliste indépendant essayiste
enseignant à sciences po auteur des
tyrans d'afrique on voit votre livre
merci vincent d'être avec nous michel
duclos on va démarrer avec vous comment
pourriez vous définir la politique
étrangère dit emmanuel macron à l'issue
de ce quinquennat et il en continuité ou
en rupture avec ses prédécesseurs
ce qui me frappe le plus c'est qu'il a
été un président visionnaire quelqu'un
qui
aime les concepts et qui en particulier
sur l'europe a su définir un concept
moteur la souveraineté européenne ou
l'autonomie stratégique européenne et
qui avait une certaine force je crois
parce que c'était au moment où il a très
bien conceptualiser ou un assist et
parallèlement à la montée des nouveau
autoritaire et des populistes et un
certain retrait des états unis des
affaires du monde c'était très important
que l'europe prenne en main son destin
et là je dois dire pendant trois ans il
a trouvé porte close où il a prêché dans
le désert et puis la faire du co vide a
fait que ces idées ont été
confirmés et que l'europe c'est
davantage un des grès est organisé comme
il l'avait préconisé dès maintenant nous
assistons à deuxième choc avec la guerre
en ukraine et c'est à nouveau la
question de la capacité de l'europe à
faire face et à se durcir qui est en
mesure vision européenne et des
résultats donc vous dites sur le plan
européen est ce qu'il ya une ligne
matheron je crois que c'est quelqu'un
qui a des intuitions forte mais qui
souffre à mon avis de deux handicaps
l'un est générationnel il a été rattrapé
sur le tard par le tragique de
l'histoire et c'est le cas aujourd'hui
alors qu'il est plutôt d'une génération
de l'insouciance génération dorée dans
tous les sens du terme et son deuxième
handicap à mon sens c'est précisément sa
virtuosité intellectuelle c'est à dire
qu'il a ceci de commun avec un dominique
de villepin qu'il croit dans le pouvoir
performatif du verbe et il est persuadé
me semble-t-il que j'ai regardé ça de
près sur la libye par exemple de pouvoir
convaincre tous ses interlocuteurs parce
que il a une aptitude à comprendre la
complexité d'une équation internationale
qui il faut dire assez remarquable et
par exemple sur la libye il a cru ou
voulu croire un moment que le fait de
réunir dans un château de la république
à la celle saint cloud les deux
protagonistes en l'occurrence khalifa
haftar et
elle sa rage suffirait à infléchir le
cours des mr bah non ça se passe pas
comme ça et par ailleurs puisqu'on
parlait des intuitions je pense qu'il a
un rapport à l'histoire qui est très
intéressant en dépit de ce que je disais
tout à l'heure à dire que sur le rwanda
il est allé plus loin qu'aucun de ses
prédécesseurs avec notamment la commande
de ce rapport de la commission du clerc
dont on connaît les co et puis les
restitution de biens pillés pendant
l'ère coloniale son regard sur la guerre
d'algérie son regard sur la l'esclavagé
la colonisation
donc c'est très contrastées parce que
des scènes manière je pense que comme
souvent en ces matières son pire ennemi
c'est lui-même et et son brio
michel duclos dans la guerre en ukraine
en tout cas la france sanctionne la
russie mais c'est vrai qu'elle garde un
dialogue une sorte de dialogue avec
vladimir poutine est ce que c'est un
classique de la politique étrangère
française
est ce que c'est de la rive politique
est-ce que c'est dû en même temps alors
je dirais que c'est complètement un
classique c'est à dire que macron on l'a
dit l'un et l'autre à des intuitions
original il a une capacité de
d'articuler des visions très personnel
et en même temps sur beaucoup de sujets
il faut pas se le cacher il a repris les
fondamentaux de la politique étrangère
française alors lesquels alors
là frais que c'est évidemment une
préoccupation fondamentale de toujours
des français il l'a pas mal renouvelée
à mon sens en connaissant beaucoup de
déboires aussi il faut il faut le
reconnaître et la russie ça c'est une
une ligne très traditionnelle qu'on
attribue au général de gaulle d'ailleurs
mais en réalité ça traverse toutes les
républiques et la la il l'a cru
effectivement à
la relation personnelle il n'a pas perçu
que s'adressait un ancien du kgb
l'alchimie personnel avait peu de
chances de de fonctionner et puis
surtout il a cette vision que on peut en
discutant avec les russes répondent à
leurs griefs à leurs préoccupations de
sécurité et organiser leur le la
sécurité européenne avec eux alors que
ça peut être été vrai à un moment donné
beaucoup de gens le pensent mais en tous
les cas depuis 2011 2012 on à faire face
à un poutine qui est dans l'antagonisme
systématique systématique à l'égard de
l'occident dans la polarisation et donc
il y avait très peu de chances que avec
ce putin là on puisse progresser et
quand même ce qui est mystérieux chez
monsieur macron c'est que il n'a obtenu
aucun résultat il a été de déboires en
déboires il a continué malgré tout à
parler quoi qu'il arrive à poutine et a
théorisé la nécessité de parler à
poutine qu'ils continuent à ce qui fait
preuve de naïveté alors candeur naïve t
il apprend il apprend vite c'est à dire
que là aussi ce handicap c'est qu' il
n'avait pas une perception dire et
intuitive de la brutalité du monde et là
aussi il a été rattrapé par une certaine
forme d'ensauvagement des sénatoriales
dont poutine est une incarnation assez
archétypale et je crois que là aussi il
apprend en marchant si j'ose dire mais
qu'il après il apprend vite
j'en veux pour preuve aussi que quand
vous voyez son discours sur les régimes
tyranniques autoritaire
il peut poser un diagnostic qui est tout
à fait pertinent mais je ne suis pas sûr
qu'ils aient l'outillage du cynisme
nécessaire en diplomatie donc on verra
on verra ce que ça donne par ailleurs
alors s'agissant de l'ukraine on ne peut
pas lui dénier une certaine forme de
cohérence dans le constat qui est le
sien que de toute façon un jour viendra
où il faudra parler avec poutine et que
de toute façon sauf à considérer que
celui ci verra sa destinée brutalement
être interrompue dans un corridor du
kremlin il y aura un jour un compromis
on n'a jamais vu un conflit armé se
termine autrement que par
l'anéantissement de l'adversaire ou par
des concessions et un accord prend les
devants oui donc
disqualifié poutine en disant de toute
façon on ne peut pas parler avec
quelqu'un comme ça ça ne fait pas
beaucoup avancer les choses me
semble-t-il chef du clan tout car en
europe on n'a pas anticipé le fait que
cette invasion de vladimir poutine de
l'ukraine alors que les américains
effectivement eu en parlait pourquoi en
particulier la france et l'allemagne bah
écoutez il ya certainement diverses
explications mais pour moi
malheureusement l'explication principale
c'est justement cette perception que
nous avions et que peut-être nous avons
encore de vladimir poutine c'est à dire
cette impression que finalement c'est un
homme brutal méchant qui temps en temps
des rap mais c'est quand même un
interlocuteur fiable
c'est quelqu'un dont je crois on n'avait
pas compris à quel point c'était un
adversaire de nos intérêts c'était un
ennemi si vous voulez donc naïveté c'est
pas exactement l'irénisme s'est pas joué
c'est ça ça plus de les réviser ces deux
facettes une erreur de jugement sur
l'interlocuteur qu'on a en face de soi
et donc à partir du moment où on avait
ce prisme on pouvait pas imaginer qu'ils
feraient quelque chose qui dans notre a
dans notre perception des choses est
absurbe or tant il est malade alors il y
avait il n'y avait pas que maiden c'est
vrai que cette justice
aux analystes les buts visés écrit tout
était ouvert s'il suffisait de lire ses
textes il suffisait de relire ses
discours et interviews pour comprendre
qu'il n'y avait eu aucun mystère en
réalité dans sa posture mais là encore
je pense que effectivement quand je
parle d'iris je veux dire que d'une
certaine manière
quelqu'un comme macron parce qu'il est
de sa génération et parce qu'il est du
cursus qui est le sien ne pouvait pas
imaginer par exemple que au fond la
tyrannie n'était pas soluble dans
l'économisme ça a été la grande tragédie
pas seulement de la france mais aussi de
l'allemagne d'angela merkel dont
apparemment la canonisation est retardée
de quelques décennies maintenant parce
qu'on s'est aperçu à quel point ses
illusions lyriques sur la une sont pas
là ma situation je dis non mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que il ya cette idée
que il peut avoir des méthodes de
soudard
et puis nous un comportement de
nostalgie impériale de tsar impénitent
et c'est qu'avec l'économie allait
pouvoir faire des échanges et qu'il y
aurait des intérêts réciproques etc et
c'est là où je pense l'europe plus que
macron lui-même le doubs tonnerre ça
fait preuve oui exactement de grande
candeur elle et l'afrique michel duclos
l'afrique alors et manama qu'on voulait
sortir de la françafrique on se souvient
de ce discours de ouagadougou alors quel
bilan cinq ans après compliqué j'ai un
peu de doute sur l'explication
générationnel je dois dire parce que
justement il me semble que cette idée de
d'être bienveillant compréhensif avec
les tyrans pour des raisons historiques
géographiques etc c'est quelque chose
qui passait jadis il semble que les
jeunes générations maintenant voit quand
même davantage soyons clairs le bien et
le mal alors sur l'afrique à mon sens là
pour le coup il a joué la carte de la
jeunesse là il ya un phénomène
générationnel c'est pas à moi de dire
s'il a réussi ou pas mais en tous les
cas il à jouer sur cette corde je crois
qu'il a joué sur la corde comme vous
l'avez indiqué de d'essayer de sortir du
de l'afrique francophone mais là aussi
c'est pas d'une très grande originalité
ses prédécesseurs ont tous essayé il a
joué plus que ses prédécesseurs et
saint-vincent il y avait lyon la
question de la mémoire glace et là où il
était le plus original ou fond c'est là
où il a essayé de renouveler alors
apparemment on n'a jamais été aussi
impopulaire dans un freak de l'ouest
donc ça n'a pas suffi mais ce sont des
choses qui se joue à long terme et puis
il a peut-être mieux encore que ses
prédécesseurs monsieur chirac je crois
avait beaucoup essayé jouer les enjeux
globaux c'est quelqu'un qui s'intéresse
beaucoup si vous voulez ou au
développement
au changement climatique
à l'organisation de la régulation de la
globalisation et il a très bien compris
que le continent africain était le
continent par excellence où ça se jouer
et là il à me semble-t-il
imprimait une marque personnelle et
peut-être tracer une orientation
nouvelle
et paris a également offre coup de froid
avec l'algérie salut ma bienveillance
mansuétude je reviens juste de visionner
dessus ce que j'entends par là c'est au
fond une fois une sorte de culte dans la
capacité de résoudre par l'économie des
tensions qui ont sont d'une autre nature
qui viennent d'une névrose historique
salissantes petit alors sur l'afrique
s'ils voulaient là le bilan est très
contrastée parce que moi que me disent
mes interlocuteurs africains notamment
de la jeune génération ils me demandent
toujours mais il est où le vrai macron
est-ce que c'est celui qui dénonce des
dérives tyrannique des bricolages
constitutionnel des troisième mandat
fatale ou est-ce que c'est celui qui se
précipitent n'djamena pour adouber une
succession dynastique et couleur kaki et
ça ça rend le message de la france macro
nien absolument indéchiffrable pour la
plupart de nos instructeurs africain
j'ajoute un autre élément car parfois
l'excès de soin apporté à la forme
brouille également le message bon ils
sont que j'ai assisté d'assez près au
sommet afrique-france nouvelles manières
de montpellier a sommé sans chefs d'état
sauf un lui en majesté et puis le numéro
de claquettes avec les jeunes africains
qui étaient tous extrêmement intégré
choisit parfois par le quai d'orsay et
cetera je suis désolé ça ne fonctionne
pas ça fait un beau moment de théâtre
mais c'est pas ça qui imprime une
nouvelle rythmique et sur les erreurs
bah euh moi pour moi l'erreur c'est
exactement ce que j'ai départ à travers
l'épisode tchadien c'est de rendre
illisible un message volontariste et
j'ajoute un point pour en avoir discuté
avec plusieurs chefs d'état africains un
sahélien en ouest africain c'est qu'il
ya quelque chose qui ne passe pas dans
sa méthode avec ses homologues africains
lahmadi à programme de la démographie
dans tel pays sahélien que je ne cite
pas à dessein on peut tout se dire à
huis clos entre nous et son diagnostic
sur les difficultés qui sont les nôtres
a maîtrisé notre essor démographique
sont parfaitement recevable mais on ne
fait pas la leçon en public et donc ça
parfois ça a été aussi très
contre-productif par rapport à son
audience auprès de ses homologues
subsahariens piégeurs d'afrique et
madame la con michel 2 go pour l'instant
et effectivement on n'en parle pas parce
que le crâne
ravi toute l'actualité mais quand même
notre situation au mali la
reconfiguration de nos forces
disons pas que c'est un échec parce que
c'est plus compliqué que ça mais en tous
les cas c'est une situation très
difficile à vivre et là je dirais autant
les circonstances ont servi les desseins
du président en europe autant en afrique
cette succession de coups d'état et même
si vous voulez ce qui s'est passé en
ethiopie qui aurait put un grand
partenaire pour l'afrique et les enjeux
globaux le soudan aussi tout ça c'est
une série de circonstances qui l'ont
desservi des ratés
des ratés bas je je je suis comme
vincent je constate qu'à partir du
moment où nos interlocuteurs africains
le critique mais tant qu sa cohérence
c'est qu'il ya quelque chose qui n'a pas
marché et en termine avec la relation
avec les etats-unis est-il atlantiste
emmanuel macron il avait parlé de la
mort cérébrale de l'otan aujourd'hui on
parle du réveil de l'otan avec cette
guerre en ukraine vincent
je ne le vois pas or à tort ou à raison
comme j'ai un atlantiste de stricte
obédience je crois que c'est quelqu'un
qui considère qu'il fallait remettre à
plat nos relations avec les états unis
comme d'ailleurs avec la russie ce qu'il
a tenté de faire avec le succès que l'on
sait je crois que c'est plutôt quelqu'un
qui en gros s'inscrit dans une sorte
d'héritage pour le coup golo
mitterrandien ou alors il ya la fois il
ya un mélange
d'intérêts pour l' aventure que
représente la démocratie américaine et
de méfiance par rapport au prurit
parfois dominateur voir néo impérialiste
de l'émission américaine mais là encore
et je termine sur cette image ce n'est
pas parce qu'on soutient les changes de
la poignée de mains rugueuses et viril
avec donald trump que l'on fait fléchir
l'intéressé non je retourne sur cette
idée qu'il y a parfois une confusion
entre la forme et le fond michel duclos
je crois qu'il a un problème avec les
états unis
sa fascination pour trump est peut-être
un peu malsaine il faut bien le dire il
n'a pas bien fait le passage de trump à
bail donne jusqu'à la faire hocus donc
les sous marins australiens qui lui ont
permis grâce une crise bilatérale très
classique de rétablir une relation
fauteuses toi le cadre d'une coopération
avec la maison blanche le temps il ne
comprend pas ça c'est souvent le cas de
beaucoup de montpellier ne considère pas
il ne comprend pas que pour nos
partenaires c'est sacré et que donc pour
nous français que nous on est on idée
et des laïcs dans un monde où les autres
voient ça comme une religion si vous
laissez pas qu'on est contre le temps
ces coûts pour nous ça n'a jamais
souhaité en sortir c'est bon bah non
mais revoir à 10 juste titre parce que
sur un plan opérationnel ça n'aurait pas
de sens mais il a du mal à percevoir la
culture de nos partenaires européens sur
la question de l'otan et donc laisse
donc des états unis
l'état de mort cérébrale dont on se
souvient un qui avait suscité un tollé à
l'époque dirait que le cadavre en
question il bouge encore et qu'il doit à
vladimir poutine d'ailleurs retrouver
aujourd'hui une nouvelle vigueur et
surtout la saa par ces propos qui
étaient justifiées qui pour nous
français vont de soi il sait inutilement
coupé de nos partenaires la même chose
sur le dialogue avec avec la russie où
on peut être pour ou contre peu importe
mais à partir du moment où vous êtes un
grand leader européen si vous ne tenez
pas compte des sensibilités de vos
partenaires européens vous réduisez
votre capacité d'entraînement ccct saad
et grands des grandes lacunes de la
diplomatie macro nian il orientera les
notamment de pologne pour ne citer que
ce pays hôte l'otan avec tous ses
défauts est perçu comme l'assurance vie
par rapport à une menace à la fois
historique et géopolitique donc c'est
clair que ça n'est pas très bien passée
à varsovie donc pas atlantiste et donc a
pas un vrai atlantiste en tous les cas
merci à tous les deux en tout cas merci
beaucoup vincent et je d'avoir été avec
nous un journaliste indépendant merci à
vous michel duclos donc d'avoir évoqué
cette politique français cette
diplomatie française on a compris qu'il
y avait tout de même une ligne emmanuel
macron on a fait le bilan de ses cinq
années de ce quinquennat du président
emmanuel macron